so we have the function G of X is equal
to x squared times the natural log of X
and what I want to do in this video is
see if we can figure out the absolute
extrema for G of X so are there X values
where G takes on an absolute maximum
value or an absolute minimum value
sometimes you might call them a global
maximum or global minimum so the first
thing I like to think about is well it's
just what's the just what's the domain
for which G is actually defined and we
know that in the natural log of X this
the the argue that the input into
natural log it has to be greater than
zero so the domain the domain is all
real numbers greater than zero so X has
to be greater than zero anything lateral
log of zero is not defined there is no
power that you could take e to to get to
zero and natural log of negative numbers
is not defined so that is the domain the
domain is all real numbers such that all
real numbers X such that X is greater
than zero so our absolute extrema have
to be within that domain so to find
these let's see if we can find some
local extrema and see if any of them are
good candidates for absolute extrema and
we could find our local extrema by
looking at looking at critical points or
critical values so let's take the
derivative of G so G prime will just in
a new color just for kicks
alright so G prime of X is equal to we
could use the product rule here so
derivative of x squared which is 2x
times the natural log of x plus x
squared times the derivative of natural
log of X so that is 1 over X and I can
just rewrite that x squared times 1 over
X and we're going to assume where that X
is positive so that is going to be that
is going to be adjust and actually I
didn't have to make that assumption for
what I'm about to do x squared divided
by X is just going to be X all right and
so that is G prime so now let's think
about the critical critical points
critical points are where the derivative
are their points in the domain so
they're going to have to satisfy X is
great
than zero such that G prime is either is
either undefined or it is equal to zero
so let's first think about when G prime
is equal to zero so let's set it equal
to zero to X natural log of X plus X is
equal to zero well we can subtract we
could subtract X from both sides of that
and so we get 2x natural log of X is
equal to negative X see if we divide
both sides by X and we can do that we
know X isn't going to be 0 our domain is
X is greater than 0 so this is going to
be actually let's divide both sides by
2x so that we get the natural log of X
is equal to negative 1/2 negative X
divided by 2x is negative 1/2 or we
could say that X is equal to e to the
negative 1/2 is equal to X remember
natural log is just log base E so e to
the negative 1/2 which we could also
write like that e to the negative 1/2 or
1 over the square root of e so that's a
point at which at which G at which at
which our derivative I should say is
equal to zero it is a critical point or
critical value for our original function
G so and that's the only place where G
prime is equal to zero are there any
other points where G prime is undefined
and there have to be points within the
domain so let's see what would make this
undefined the 2x and the x that you can
evaluate for any X natural log of X once
again is only going to be defined for X
greater than zero but that's we've
already restricted ourselves to that
domain so within the domain any point in
the domain our derivative is actually
going to be defined so given that let's
see what's happening on either side of
this critical point on either side of
this critical point and I could draw a
little number line here to to really
help us visualize this so it's if this
is negative one this is zero this is
let's see what e to the this is going to
be like one
/ boy this is a this is going to be a
little bit less than one so let's see
let me plot one here and then to here
and so we have a critical point at one
over the square root of e let me put it
right over there one over the square
root of E and we know that we're only
defined from for all x is greater than
zero so let's think about the interval
between 0 and this critical point right
over here so the open interval from 0 to
1 over the square root of e let's think
about whether G prime is positive or
negative there and then let's think
about it for for X greater than 1 over
the square root of E so that's the
interval from 1 over square root of e 2
in affinity so over that yellow interval
well let's just try out a value that is
in there so let's just try G prime of I
don't know let's try G prime of 0.1 Z
prime of 0.1 is definitely going to be
in this interval and so it's going to be
equal to two point two times 0.1 is
equal to is equal to zero point two
times the natural log of 0.1 plus 0.1
and let's see this right over here this
is going to be a negative value in fact
it's going to be quite it's it's
definitely going to be greater than
negative one because e to the negative
one is only gets you to let's see e to
the negative one is one over e so that's
1 over two point seven so 1 over two
point seven is going to be so this is
going to be around around 0.3 or 0.4 so
in order to get point 1 so this will be
around 0.23 to 0.4 so in order to get to
0.1 you have to be even more negative so
this is going to be this is going to be
I could say less than negative 1 so this
is less than negative 1 and I'm
multiplying it times 0.2
going to get a negative value that is
less than less than negative 0.2 and if
I'm adding 0.1 to it well I'm still
going to get a negative value so over
this yellow interval G prime of X is
less than zero and it would be I should
have gotten a calculator or I could have
gotten a calculator out I could have
just evaluated a lot easier so G prime
of X is less than zero in this interval
and let's see in this blue interval
what's going on and this will be easier
we could just try out the value one so G
prime of one is equal to two times the
natural log of one plus one natural log
of one is just zero so all of this just
simplifies to one so over this blue
interval light I sample the point there
G prime of X is greater than zero so it
looks like our function is decreasing
from zero to one over square root of E
and then we increase after that and we
increase for for all X's f that are
greater than one over the square root of
e and so our function is going to hit if
we're decreasing into that and then
increasing after that we're hitting a
global minimum point or an absolute
minimum point at x equals one over the
square root of e so let me write this
down
we hit a we hit a absolute absolute
minimum minimum at x equals one over the
square root of E and there is no
absolute maximum as we get above 1 over
square root of E we are just going to
think about what's going to be happening
here we're just going to 1 we know that
our function just keeps on increasing
and increasing and increasing forever
and you can look at even this x squared
is just going to get unbounded towards
infinity and natural log of X it's going
to grow slower than x squared but it's
still going to go unbounded towards
infinity so there's no global or no
absolute maximum no absolute maximum
point and now let's look at the graph of
this to feel a little good about what we
just did analytically without looking at
it graphically and I looked at it ahead
of time so let me copy and paste it and
so this is the graph of our function so
as we can see when this point right over
here this is when this is one over the
square root of E it's not obvious from
looking at it that it's that point x
equals one over the square root of e and
we can see that it is indeed an absolute
minimum point here and there is no
absolute maximum point that it as
there's arbitrarily high values that our
function can take on